senti qualcuno al piano di sopra scritti
questo rumore di pasti ma io non sento
niente quando non si sentono più mi
raccomando se ti chiamo perché ho visto
qualcosa da stare subito che scappa
scappa vitale c'è qualcosa avevo regioni
c'è qualcosa questo
[Musica]
no
nuovamente i centimetri know i sentiti
anche voi nuovamente i pasti al piano di
sopra
ma tanto vitale non mi crederà mai mi è
venuta unite resisterò i suoni con il
cellulare e poi glieli farò sentire così
vitale non potrà non credermi perché
avrò una prova
ok iniziamo a registrare vitale devo
farti sentire una cosa ti ricordi i
rumori dei pasti che sentiva l'altro
giorno che tu non mi hai creduto
i passeri se me li ricordo no non sono
pasta lì sono veri passi siccome non mi
credi
ho registrato dei suoni così non potrei
non credermi perché ho tutti i suoni
ecco qua registrazione numero 8 play mi
sento gli uccelli che cinguetta no no
non è possibile leo registrati prima
perché non si sente niente
sì certo va bene un altro dei tuoi
scherzi io ritorno a mangiare nel
frattempo è già com'è possibile che non
si sentono i pasti che ho registrato
sentiti vero registrazione numero 8 non
si sente niente non perché i pasti
iniziano a sentirsi solo quando non c'è
vitale si sta avvicinando meglio
chiudere la porta a chiave
marino non volessi istinto qui con me
proteggermi stai dormendo
no
[Musica]
berlino
forse è meglio dei video nasconderci
vitale sei tu che mi stai facendo uno
scherzo sei tu la dietro alla porta e
succede
[Musica]
c'è qualcuno qua sopra
non c'è nessuno sono caduti ciucci
pupazzi c'è qualcuno qua fuori dalla
porta evitare sei tu
[Musica]
ora basta mi sono stancata ho deciso
anche se vitale non mi crede tornerò al
piano di sopra e il controller o
nuovamente che cosa c'è al piano di
sopra
anzi proverò a catturarla se voi mi
credete
lasciate un mi piace sotto questo video
però voglio comunque avvisare vitale
magari vuole venire con me meglio avere
qualcuno per coprirmi le spalle vitale
sarà mangiando vitale vieni che cosa
stavi facendo mangiando e dopo vedremo
prepotenti io so che non mi credi anche
se è appena successo che ho sentito
nuovamente i rumori e sono caduti i
pupazzi dalla storia questi sono tutti
da sopra perché li ho messi a posto
altrimenti berlino li avrebbe
sgranocchiati tutti frena mente questi
rumori non si sentono solamente quando
tu sei qua mi spieghi come possibile
forse immaginando turno del duo
testolina o no non me li sto immaginando
loro li hanno sentiti ho deciso che
tornerò al piano di sopra e questa volta
porterò qualcosa con me per catturare
qualsiasi cosa sia sopra che sia una
creatura o qualcos'altro magari ha solo
bisogno di mangiare lo so magari può
essere uno scoiattolo un passerotto un
topolino
lo facciamo avvicinare così potrai
rendere conto che si tratta solo di una
piccola creatura
l'ultima volta che ho controllato gli
scoiattoli non usavano le scarpe non si
sentivano i pasti quindi tu dici che la
soluzione e portargli qualcosa da
mangiare
sì anzi la vado a prendere subito
posizione potrei prendere quanto tu
stesso bene allora tu vai cerca qualcosa
da mangiare e io prenderò qualcos'altro
invece e con i ragazzi ho preso un
qualcosa per catturare la creatura da
una corda beh spero che funzioni
semplicemente salirò su e cercherò di
legare
come portarla al piano di sotto per
vedere che cos'è esattamente dato per
finito vitale vitale sbrigati ecco ho
preso il fare per i passerotti per
mourinho per i passerotti o per i
topolini non penso che il pane servirà
un bel niente
senti ascoltati devo spiegare il mio
piano è questa è una corda il mio piano
è questo
saliremo in g al piano di sopra
cercheremo la creatura e io cercherò di
legarla con la corda tu dovrai guardarmi
le spalle ok ma mi sembra un po
esagerato una corda per prendere uno
scoiattolo dei passerotti non provi mia
hai mangiato il pane la rubato dalla
sopra bene te l'avevo detto che il pane
numero una buona idea quindi vai e
prendi qualcos'altro per catturare la
creatura ok ma io chiamo che è più
gratuito e amico come quando guardava
già preso questa volta ho preso i minimi
per i fossero così li possiamo dare da
mangiare ai fossero attivi non trovi mi
batterò tesi sono di passeri
probabilmente quelle che stanno sopra
e così con questi sei mini gli darebbe
da mangiare magari questa creatura erbe
ora devo prendere magari qualche qualche
cosa cosa di perderla questa creatura
per attirarlo per darli da mangiare non
so tipo delle erbe di campo dei
fiorellini del dei fiorellini quindi il
tuo piano è portare a questa creatura
del pane dei seri e un mazzo di fiori a
farlo non c'è niente da fare evitare non
mi crederà mai a meno che non vedrà la
creatura con i suoi occhi e se io
riuscirò a catturarla lui la vedrà ea
quel punto capirà che avevo ragione fin
dall'inizio
beh vitale non torna più allora io
inizio a salire ad andare
e poi ho preso un po di erbette e un po
di fiori ma capito nel vivo ora quindi
gli piace che si questa composizione che
gli ho appena fatto che a bersi va bene
tu porta gli pure i tuoi fiori semi e
pane però l'importante che mi guardi le
spalle ok io proverò a catturarlo con la
corda tu stai molto attento e proteggimi
ok alle orde di capo vi serve il calcolo
sicuro che non ti serve nient'altro
no credo di no ok allora andiamo dicendo
anzi vai tu avanti io ti guardo alle
spalle è così e il malore che potreste
accendere una luce per caso sì certo
ok ora riesco a vederci qualcosa almeno
mi raccomando non accendere le luci
principali perché potremmo spaventare la
creatura e potrebbe essere ancora peggio
che illustra ragione si quindi teniamo
solo questa luce blu di coin che non
dovrebbe disturbarla ma che cos'è in
mano i fiori
vabbè senti iniziamo a cercare ok
berlino sta già cercando tieni gli occhi
bene aperti e guardati intorno perché
potresti vedere degli occhi
all'improvviso ed aiuto poi con quei
fiori a stavo cercando di come si dice
proteggervi certe nera la corda a
portata di mano ei sì
io non sento davvero nessun rumore sei
sicura che lei sentiti
sì ho anche visto due occhi la scorsa
volta solo che ora non si sente più
niente non so perché ma quando ci sei tu
qua con me non si vede né si sente
niente com'è possibile ho capito forse
ha paura di me allora perché dovrebbe
avere paura di te forse perché sa che tu
oggi tutto il cibo e gli ruberà scherzi
bozzi forza paura di quello rino marino
che sei mangiato ei dove sta andando
berlino si intitola vai a prendere
berlino io continuo ad esplorare fa ok
forse berlino sto seguendo qualche
traccia
casey ha azionato qualcosa di
elettronico forse non è stata una buona
idea salire costume non si sente niente
c'è nessuno vitale sei tu
[Musica]
sembrano dei rumori di farfalle
libellule qualcosa con le ali
[Musica]
vitale vitale berlino dove siete
sapevo che sarebbe finita così dove
sparito vitale perché vitale sparisse
sempre in queste situazioni però ora che
sono andati via
inizio a sentire dei rumori quindi forse
la creatura si farà viva adesso chi sei
senti non voglio farti del male
qualunque cosa tu sia
voglio solo capire che cosa se io chi
sei ok puoi mostrarti per favore
[Musica]
vitale vento qualcosa si sta avvicinando
la creatura vitale o non la luce come si
riaccende ecco come faccio a spegnersi
da sola i passi li sentite sono tornati
i passi vitale sei tu
[Musica]
la porta questa porta si è chiusa da
solo e nessuno c'è qualcuno qua c'è
nessuno prova a sentire se c'è qualcosa
non sento più niente
forse è stato il vento a chiudere la
porta pro fosse di armi qua e ad
aspettare e tosta e continuo a sentire i
rumori
ok ragazzi mi sono seduta qua dietro
questa porta perché questa porta si è
chiusa all'improvviso non so se è stato
il vento o qualcos'altro
in più ho sentito dei rumori strani
provenire da qua quindi è meglio che mi
tengo pronta con la corda qua è meglio
che sorvegli tutto è stato se son finiti
vitale merlino perché se ne sono andati
via così all'improvviso
vabbé fa niente mela sbrigherò io questa
situazione l'importante è che prendo
qualsiasi cosa sia con la corda
certo
ciao
[Musica]